oh you didn't think of it yesterday what
the Freak is that with that you're only
a ridiculously jet-lagged and sick and
your wife is sick too and you're working
15 hours a day but you should feel in a
good video we don't care what your
Excuse is you're being punished it's
about time that you were punished again
honestly and I'm looking forward to it
so aside from everyone putting
punishment ideas in the comments I have
a couple of things to talk about really
quick first dftba records is doing
something kind of awesome we're putting
together a street team and it's right
and you can be a member
we're asking people to help us promote
dftba records stuff and we're giving
away some pretty cool prizes in the
process so there's a link in the sidebar
straight to the page you can see street
team's mission number one and that is to
use reverbnation widgets to collect
email addresses from people who are
interested in dftba records and the
person who collects the most gets a free
iPod shuffle laser inscribed that says
dftba records preloaded with five dftba
releases including so jokes
the dftba compilation and chameleon
circuits new album which and because it
would be wrong to just pick my record
label and this void left behind by
john's not making a video on sunday i'm
going to share with you a clip that i
took at leakycon of maureen johnson
explaining exactly where the in your
pants phenomenon began turns out it has
nothing to do with john green's genius
and everything to do with john green's
bagel enjoy and when you are done
remember to post punishment ideas below
and if you're interested join up with
the dftba records street team take it
away maureen how many points so he went
and he got a toasted bagel with cream
cheese
he was like that's all i can eat like
this morning or something so he was sort
of flailing around a little bit with his
bagel and he got so animated that he
dropped his bagel into his own lap cream
cheese down he lifted it up and all this
cream cheese had gotten like into the
grooves of the quarter i so i was
sitting next to him and i became sort of
fixated on all this cream cheese he had
in his pants and we were talking about
book titles because ii lockhart was
trying to figure out what she ended up
eventually calling the disrupted full
history of frankie bono banks and she
said oh I need a new title and we were
just thinking
titles and I was looking at this sort of
cream cheese John already had cream
cheese in his own pants and I was like
you know if you just are putting in your
pants on anything it gets better you
know looking for allies get in your
pants abundance of katherines and you're
panting those were the first ones and
then we just did that for the rest of
the day and nothing else was
accomplished except us every once in a
while trying to write for five minutes
looking up and pick up another title and
saying in your pants and that's how a
movement starts all because John Green
doesn't know how to eat